where do our cities in southern nevada
rank when it comes to apartment living
and working from home well we're going
to get to that list in just a moment as
more than a year since the pandemic
began many americans have gotten used to
working from home some permanently
others more long-term remote but not
every home is equal in the world of
working from home
apartment dwellers have unique
challenges like space
noise convenience infrastructure some
cities are better made for this
environment than others
here's a look at apartment guides best
cities to work from home
based on rent and square footage for an
average two-bedroom apartment
fastest internet speeds and fastest
carriers you can see chandler arizona is
america's best city for this category
las vegas ranks 17th north las vegas
comes in 23rd and henderson
38th in the country well thanks to our
no state income tax we do continue to
see a huge influx of californians
relocating here both as home buyers as
we've been reporting and apartment
renters
people really can live wherever they
want right now because you don't have to
live in san francisco to work for any of
the big tech companies in silicon valley
and they're looking for an alternative
uh las vegas is an attractive option for
them because
of just some of these more affordable
rents and the wi-fi and the
infrastructure and everything
within las vegas obviously a big tourist
city lots of people coming in a lot of
people spending money there
there is a lot of infrastructure in
place that is beneficial
to your ability to work from home you're
going to have good wi-fi connections
you're going to have good internet
speeds brian carvery managing editor of
apartment guide
says people are looking for properties
that offer co-worker space in
say the clubhouse or just a dedicated
workspace inside the apartment unit